let's get started how is everyone
you know why you're so excited because
it's a goody bag day
and i i'm not i'm not
going to deny you a weekend of goody bag
action which is why you're getting it
today even though
the topic in the goody bag is
crystallography
we will not start talking about
crystallography
until monday but i didn't want to wait i
know you didn't want to wait to have
these models
um in your hands because it's an
enhancement of your weekend activities
so the goody bag again just sort of like
last time i'm giving it out to you today
but the topic will start on monday
um today instead we're going to talk
about metals
and metallic bonding and the properties
of metals that are related to the kind
of bond that you get in metals
and you know we kind of motivated
band theory of solids with conductivity
and we talked about conductivity there's
a chart
of conductivity and there's some
elements in there some elements and some
uh some materials that are more
complicated
right like glass isn't necessarily one
element or silica
there's diamonds silicon germanium
copper and we talked about
insulators semiconductors and i've
mentioned metals
and that's what i want to focus on today
we did this in the context of the bands
right so remember here you've got your
your um conduction band and here you've
got your valence band and the valence
band is filled
and so if there's a large gap that's the
gap
if it's large like you know over three
and a half ev
then it's an insulator and then the
the one in between we talked about a lot
on wednesday
that you know if if this is your gap and
it's say
between you know zero
uh to 3.5 ev then
that's a semiconductor and so you know
that's what we talked about that's in
your goodie bag we talked a lot about
semiconductors
and then we talked about how well if you
have some kind of
band that is filled in the middle there
so it's it doesn't have to be filled in
the middle it could be filled here it
could be filled up here
but the point is that the filling of
electrons does not
stop where there's a forbidden zone
of states right where there's no states
that's what this is that's what a gap is
it's a gap of electron
freedom right whereas in a metal there
is no such thing because you fill
up to a point where then right above
that infinitesimally tiny bit of energy
away
there's a free state right there's a
free state so you're in the middle of a
band
and that's a metal well i mean this is
you know so
so we should say that the gap here has
to be greater than zero here the gap
would be equal to zero
there's no gap you can't define a gap in
a metal
and we talked about semiconductor
problems i looked up
just for fun you know i mean why not
because
of course you do it late at night you
look up old exam problems and you play
with them
and you know okay so from last exam
right so this is for the semiconductors
we had oh here's a good question
2.8 centimeters cubed
of uh pure germanium
now i want to highlight this because
there's one more thing i want to say
about
semiconductors before i move on uh now
it's
it's doped and that's what we spent a
lot of time talking about on wednesday
it's doped
with 50 micrograms
okay of selenium that was the problem
and the first part of the problem is how
many carriers are produced
what and the same question it's like are
they n-type because then tight or are
they
p-type what type of carriers those are
things we can now answer
based on what we learned on wednesday
and so
you know you oh then you have this and
you say aha i know where to start
because
everything starts here right and and so
pure germanium
is doped well first of all where am i
this is my map
right germanium is there and now it's
doped with
selenium is selenium to the right or to
the left in the period
it's to the right right and so
right away you know if you put a
selenium in there
instead of germanium so if you take your
germanium
and put a selenium atom in it's gonna
it's gonna if it's a dopant it's gonna
be in the bonding network that germanium
was but
add electrons to it if it's to the right
right
and so you know that it's gonna be an
n-type material
and if you do the math the number
of carriers
is equal to 7.6 times 10 to the 20th
per centimeter cube now
here's something important that is twice
as many selenium atoms
twice as many because it's two over from
germanium
so it had two extra electrons for each
dopant atom
right so the way you solve these
problems you figure out how many
selenium atoms are there per centimeter
cubed
and how many electrons for each of those
acted
as a free carrier dope as good as a
dopant remember dopants simply
give you carriers either up there
if it's n-type or down here if it's
p-type
okay and this is n-type
and type okay so that's a nice
now the reason i wanted to do this is
because again it is
net you can never have enough fun doing
problems like this and looking up old
exams and stuff
but i also wanted to go back to this
picture that i drew for you on wednesday
okay so this picture was
of the number of carriers
and remember these are electrons that
carry
current right and we sort of drew
something that looked like this
now remember this is
right these are thermally activated and
this is
thermally activated activated
and these are from dopants
now which is if i put dopants in
and then i can get you a constant number
of carriers because it's just defined by
how much of the impurity i mixed in
how much impurity and i can control that
really carefully which means i can
control the number of carriers
and then eventually thermally excited
carriers will just start to dominate
but this is this ability to dope with
chemistry
is what enabled the semiconductor
revolution now
is that okay what's going on over here
what's going on in this part here right
well
you know what's going on there because
we drew this picture
on wednesday because if i have an
end type if that's my vbm and that's my
cbm
the way this works is you introduce a
donor level
right that's how doping works
right the the electrons from selenium go
into here
and then you have enough thermal energy
to get them up to there
and that's where they're free carriers
that's where they can
carry electricity and so at a certain
temperature
below which right at a certain
temperature
if you're lower than that well there's
not even enough thermal energy to get
from here to here
right not even enough to do that so it's
got to go down eventually that's what
that part is
and then one other thing i want to say
about this plot
is that we have names for this these are
called
intrinsic carriers intrinsic
and these are called extrinsic
well i mean that kind of makes sense
it's that's actually a pretty good way
to name them
because you know intrinsic means i
didn't need to do anything it's
about pure germanium pure germanium
intrinsic
i didn't do anything to the material
okay and so but it's still you can get
carriers from thermal activation
above the gap whereas if it's extrinsic
it means i did something external i
added dopants those are extrinsically
doped
okay so those are just important uh
distinguishing factors now i'm going to
come back to this plot later i want to
talk about metals metals are all the way
over here
those are semiconductors and doping them
or thermal activation gets me
carriers which gets me this conductivity
range but metals are
much much much higher metals are much
much much higher
why what is going on in metals that's so
special
okay well the way we understand
everything
is from the bonds so what is happening
in a metal there's a there's aluminum
there's aluminum
there's aluminum and there's aluminum
for us this is all we see now
we don't see any of this anymore we only
see atoms and electrons
because those are the building blocks
right
those are the building blocks and and
the thing is that
if we write down all the orbitals of an
aluminum atom there's the core
there's the shell there's another
there's these ones out here way out here
right in the case of aluminum three of
them that are really really
kind of weakly bonded right they're way
out there they're loose
they have they have the ability to come
off easily we talked about this in the
context of other properties
right uh uh you know the
the polarizability the electronegativity
right all of this feeds in everything is
determined
by where these electrons are and then
also as i mentioned
by how the atoms arrange that comes next
week
so but if they're really really kind of
almost free
then you can kind of picture it like
this let's dial it back to sodium
and you can you can kind of picture a
metal as
truly free electrons right they're truly
free they're not
they're not in they're they're in the
middle of that band and they've got all
this freedom because the states are free
all around them
and they're basically not really that
attached to any one
atom or another and this is really
the picture of the metallic bond so
let's use let's go over here
and it's they're so
they're so free when these atoms come
together with those
very very loosely bound outer electrons
those those electrons
are so free we actually call it a c we
call it the electron c
it's a simplified way to think about it
but it's a good picture
to start with so in metals
you've got this electron c electron
c we'll call it a model because it's a
way of thinking
and in this model you've got a positive
charge
nuclei so you got positively charged new
guy why because they've lost an electron
to the c
they've lost it those outer ones have
gone well
they're not gone because there's others
around too but they're all just kind of
roaming free
and so you're left with these positive
charges
right and these are the cations
positively charged nuclei are cations
right and they're in a sea of electrons
and so this is because the valence
electrons is not tightly bound this is
what i've been saying but this is why
you get it
cations so positive charge nuclei these
are cations
in a sea of electrons
now so if you think about a metal in
this way
then you understand a lot of the
properties of metals
this is a very useful way to think about
metals
and and it it let's go back to our
pictures of bonding let me use this
board here
we'll put it right under here and we're
going to finish
what we started we're going to finish
what we started
because remember we talked about
covalent
we talked about ionic and then we did
all these intermolecular forces and the
bonding
that comes about from those but we
didn't do metallic so if i do covalent
over here
and i do ionic over here well okay
covalent we know right these
are maybe h that's a covalent bond
that's a nonpolar
kind of covalent bond carrying is
sharing oh you could have hf
right where it's sort of like you know
it's a little less sharing
but it you know it's still a covalent
bond it's a polar covalent bond
right and i mean now in the ionic sense
you have sodium chloride we did that
example
where you literally chlorine is like
give me and so i'm just like okay
and that's it that's the relationship
right
but see now here let's take sodium and
let's just put a bunch of them around
well but see if i've got an electron c
then my electrons
are simply wandering around
in the c so every ion
has this kind of ocean of electrons
around it
they're not attached it'd be like if you
say
how are you going to parent well i'm
going to pair i'm going to tell
you know you can only go into the
backyard
and play that's it right you are
confined to be in the backyard
um and and now you say well okay if but
now
if i'm a proton and i'm parenting an
election i say you know what you can be
in
any yard it doesn't matter don't even
come home
i don't care like another kid's going to
come into my backyard at some point
so it's all good
that's the that is the relationship
of a metal of inside of a metal
maybe here it's like the two houses
switched kids i don't know what's going
on
no one of them just took the kid but
anyway
all right i'm going too far but here's
yo i want to give you that sense that
they're just roaming around in a sea
they're roaming around they're roaming
around now
here's the point i've got a sea of
electrons
oh oh we can finish our table
i'm gonna finish that table we started
the table let's finish the table
because now if i have metallic all right
and i have this kind of um
you know this kind of setup here right
that's the picture
that's the model and here i have cation
remember our table slash delocalized
d lok d localized
electrons and the bonding strength for
this table
in kilojoules per mole is 75 to a
thousand
that's a big range we'll talk about that
and there's an example iron we finished
our table
that's it that's the last century now
this remember
this part of the table was the basis of
attraction
remember that and we filled this out for
all the other types of bonds
the basis of attraction and
i want to point out that every single
basis we have covered involves the same
thing understanding what electrons are
doing
what is the electronic
structure that's the fundamental
principle
of of this class right that's the key
component the key ingredient that's in
all of our recipes
what are those electrons doing that
leads us to
every single one of those kinds of bonds
including metallic all right so now you
can you can imagine
how this controls the properties right
now but and but first they say
well if i had a group one metal if i had
a group one metal then i've got
two i've got one right like sodium but
if i go over to magnesium
you can see that i've got a higher
charge because
both of those electrons are likely to
leave and wander around in the sea
of electrons so that would be what
magnesium looks like in terms of this
this electron c model
but the thing is that that
the c this picture is what helps us
understand
the properties of metals and that's what
i want to talk about
that's what i want to talk about and and
these are some of the properties right
you can go through
metals and there's a whole range of
properties but these are some of the
ones that are pretty consistent
they are reflective they're shiny there
are literally settings in like photo
you know photo apps metallic
make it look metallic right
because metals are are shiny
they have luster why the
the high they have high electrical
connectivity that's the thing we talked
about a lot already
they have uh high thermal conductivity
i'll mention that
high heat capacity they're malleable and
ductile
all of these and many more properties of
metals
can be explained from this one
simple picture of the electron c
from this one simple picture okay
so let's start so if i if i think about
um
let's look at these top three okay so
i'll start
why is a metal shiny why isn't metal
shiny
well it goes back to the thing we've
been talking about all along
you know or or certainly in a lot of
parts right with the bohr model and
atoms and electrons getting excited the
semiconductors and
and leds right
it has to do with how photons interact
with the material
but see now i've got these electrons
that are sitting out there at any energy
level
ready for the photon there's not there's
no gap
right so so i've got electrons sitting
around in the sea
and they're ready for anything any kind
of energy that hits them well they've
got room to be excited
right they've got room to be excited and
it's it's that
combined with other things but it's that
that is a big part of why metals
have their shininess those electrons can
be excited
in almost any way right because there's
an infinite number of states right there
there's no gap
right so the way they can respond to
energy from photons
is is um is extremely diverse and and
you can imagine if i'm a photon and i
excite an electron
it doesn't matter what the wavelength is
that electron can fall back down and
re-emit the same
energy photon right okay
so that's uh so that's luster by the way
but now you know and you really should
do this
you i just said you know you have this
i've got electrons
i shine photons on these they might come
up and go back down
at any you know there's all this room
here for electrons to be excited there's
no
there's no gap whereas in diamond
in diamond i've got this huge gap
right remember diamond is an insulator
diamond has a gap of 5.5 electron volts
roughly
now you know why diamonds are
transparent it's of course
the electrons of course because
if you if i shine photons on this and
those photons are in
the visible you know that even if i go
all the way up to purple photons
they're not that high so any time i try
to
so i'm shining photons on my diamond and
those electrons are like can i go here
no
can i go here no can i go here no you
have to shine a very
high energy photon to excite an electron
in diamond
that's why it's transparent right
that's the reason when you go to the
store to buy diamonds you should ask
them about the electrons
that's what's making it all work
that's what explains the properties
okay but back to metals now okay so
that's uh luster
what about electrical connectivity well
it's the same thing it comes from the c
it comes from the c now if i take a wire
of copper and
i look at this as a sea of electrons
so i'm not drawing the ions they're in
there
i'm just drawing the fact that i've got
this sort of ocean of electrons
that are fairly free right
what well what what is happening when i
when i
try to when i try to move
them the way you do it is with some kind
of electromagnetic
force right you know some kind of force
and what that means is that i have a
charge
that this doesn't like right so like
it's a repulsive charge over here
it's going to push one of these into the
other one
but then that's going to feel that's
going to feel a force is going to move
and then that's going to push this one
and that's going to push that one and so
forth
that's how electricity works right
so the actual movement of the electrons
could be slow in the material
uh but the but the the current right you
can push a lot of current through
right because these ones over here feel
pretty quickly
the forces you applied over there but
they only feel it
they only feel it if you can get this
freedom
if those electrons are not free they're
going to feel this
this repulsion they're going to be like
you know what i'm stuck in my state
i'm stuck in this in this full valence
band i got nowhere to go
sorry you know put your energy into the
atom
or something else i don't know but i'm
not moving
ah but if it's a c then you can push
them and they can push each other
right and that's the same thing it's a
conceptual picture but it's the same
thing
as almost an infinite number of free
states that's what that means
right that's what that means now
if you got copper we see copper now
as something like argon with
those d electrons filled 3d 10
and an s electron here
and so if it's a copper wire those d
electrons it's all filled up in there
and they act as a way of
shielding it's a beautiful shielding so
that this is even more free and less
interested in staying around
right so copper is such a great
conductor and that whole
column is such a great conductor and
this is by the way
um oh such a good thing to do on a
friday night i'm so glad it's friday
look at this
ptable.com huh
you could spend hours on this i do
spend hours on this
property electrical conductivity and
then
it shows you like dark green is high
right
dark green is high and and then like no
coloring is low
and then you can just click around and
you just click around
i can do it now but i'll i would never
leave
but you go there and you can click on
different properties and see the trends
in the periodic table and it's a
beautiful thing
and you now can understand them because
of the ways
in which electrons behave
so you can see look at this there's
copper right so there's copper
and below that we've got silver and gold
and this is a really high
set of elements right the electrical
conductivity
in these three elements is super high
and
this is why because each k in each case
you're going down but you're filling the
d's
oh and then you're even filling f's
screening further away
really free s electrons high
conductivity
electron c right very easy to
very easy to push them around now okay
this also also goes back
to this picture because remember i snuck
it in
because it was on the graph and i didn't
take it out
but there was a a picture of silicon
where i showed
silicon increasing its intrinsic carrier
concentration with temperature
and on top of that was a metal i think
it was tungsten
now if you draw the metal it would be
way up
it would be way up right here because
it's higher
but it went this way
wow but now you know why it's totally
different
right the reason is totally different
than why this changes
but you can understand it for the same
route
which is the behavior of the electrons
so in a metal
in a semiconductor this temperature
dependence
uh here i've taken the temperature
independence away because i've doped it
but here that's the thermal activation
into a place of freedom into a place
where they can they can be free in the
conduction ban
here they're already totally free so
what's happening well when i increase
the temperature
i'm increasing the vibrations
you can imagine if these electrons are
trying to do their thing
and they're in like a sea of electrons
the last thing i want to do if i'm
moving along is to see some
big ion moving around
and if it moves more then it's going to
make me more upset
and get in my way that's temperature
but that's why this goes down and not up
right
for metals the more thermal energy you
put in the more those
ions those positive charges are positive
right are going to interfere with the
electrons being free
right oh we are understanding things
we understood why these have now you
might say why are these different
that's complicated relativity
not part of this class but if you want
to understand why these are different
from each they're all really high
why are they different it's more it goes
beyond the scope of this class but it's
also a very interesting story that has
to do with
uh on the one hand relativistic effects
okay now there's another thing which is
that if i go back to that table
and i did this i really did this a lot i
clicked back and forth
between okay electrical now look up here
thermal electrical thermal electrical
and you can click you go and you can
watch the table
and do that for like five minutes or so
and what you'll find
is almost nothing changes
you can't do that with very many
properties but for metals
and those two properties they're almost
identical again
it goes back to the sea it goes back to
the sea because
you know if you have electrons
that are free in a material
you you can also those can carry not
just electricity
but those can be the dominant carriers
of thermal energy as well and i'm not
going to go into those details i just
want to mention it
so this is actually called the vitamin
franzla
and it
basically says for these
for metals that the
thermal let's see okay i'll just write
it here
thermal
divided by electrical
conductivity for both conductivities
okay i'm putting it in parentheses it
should be thermal conductivity
divided by electrical conductivity goes
as
some constant
times the temperature and look at
so so if you look at that
so you can look at it by toggling back
and forth and see how similar these are
you can also just plot stuff or find
plots of stuff here's one
electrical conductivity this is at some
fixed temperature orders of magnitude
variation orders of magnitude variation
tons and tons of different materials
this is the vitamin france law
and it all now you know that law is
simply
a result of the fact that these free
electrons can carry both
electrical their charge as well as
thermal energy
and that the way they carry those are
are dependent on the material dependent
on
the number of electrons and the way they
bond and all that but if they carry it
in one way for one it carries it in the
same way for the other right
so that's okay look at all these things
now notice here
this word that's used a lot alloy alloy
alloy these are all you know okay alloy
and i mentioned the word alloy on
wednesday because i said if you wanted
to make a good blue
a good blue led you had gallium nitride
but it was a little too high
in its band gas so they alloyed it with
other then that meant mixing in
well that is done for metals
that is done for metals in a very wide
range
why because the metal properties that
you have
you may like some of but you may not
like
others right so like for copper
it's um you know it's it's got this
really high conductivity
but maybe you don't want it to be so
malleable what does that mean
we'll see in 10 minutes malleable
ductile
but but so what do you do well you alloy
it right
and so here's an example brass well
we know brass but now you know brass now
you really know brass you didn't know
brass you don't know
anyone or anything until you see it as
an atom
and electrons that is how you know
someone
copper with zinc substituted in a two to
one ratio copper to zinc
the conductivity drops those electrons
are not as free but they're still pretty
free
maybe they're a little more tied up in
the bonding and maybe what you've done
by alloying is changed its mechanical
properties
because i kind of want something
copper-like but i want it to have
different mechanical properties so i
alloy it
and and this is really how how
we think about materials design i need
something
to have let's say a certain set of
properties well i don't have them all
here
and i don't have them all here but how
can i use a combination
right how can i how can i use a
combination to get what i want
bronze is copper with tin four to one
ratio copper it's in connectivity drops
even more
it's not so simple right it's not so
simple as
oh if it's four to one then maybe it's
like 20 no
because it has to do with what happens
to the freedom
of these electrons that's what it has to
do with and that's more complicated
but maybe i've changed the properties in
another way that i really like
well those are substitutional
substitutional alloys means i took one
of the coppers out
and i replaced it with something else
here's brass with zinc in there
you can also have interstitial alloys
and interstitial alloys so if we we'll
be coming back to this when we talk
about crystals next week
but alloys actually when we talk about
defects
so you can have substitutional
substitutional
and you can have interstitial
this is just a preview interstitial
this is just a preview we're not going
to be
testing on this or thinking about this
much until we get to actually
putting these things in to a crystal
later
as as defects but right now i just want
to make sure you
you know you kind of see them for the
first time substitutional
interstitial why would you want one well
it depends on what properties you're
trying to change
in this case i've got i really like iron
it's really cheap it's it's
it's a cool material but i need it to be
stronger
and that's called steel and if you just
put a little bit of carbon
really not much like a percent by weight
you can dramatically change the
mechanical properties of iron
you can make it a much stronger material
there's a massive massive range
of properties and part of why metals are
so
uh tunable is because of the electron c
well i just came across this article
actually and i thought i'd show you this
just literally yesterday is that
yesterday
um i thought it was an interesting
example car wars still getting stronger
lighter to curb aluminum rise well
see the thing is that you know as you
want cars to be lighter
think fuel efficiency or range if it's
electric
right um you got to use lighter metals
and aluminum is lighter but aluminum is
more than twice as much as steel
it's a lot lighter though so so there's
there's a lot of interest
in making steel that's just iron with
carbon interstitial
and making steel stronger you can see
newest alloy that's what caught my
attention
newest alloy they've come up with
something to add to iron
to make its mechanical properties really
really good
at a very very thin layer
right because they need steel to be even
stronger
in a much thinner layer otherwise it's
too heavy and you've got to make it
really thin
and really strong those are going to be
alloys okay
back to our property list now um
malleability and ductility why
are metals malleable and ductile
well i thought this was a good place for
a video
because i really like i think it's a
really simple explanation
of malleability and ductility as it
relates to the electron c
so let's watch this it's like a minute
long
they violently repel each other breaking
the crystal apart
that's an ionic trap if you hit a metal
with a hammer
it doesn't break it just dents metals
are able to deform in response to an
applied force
the mobile sea of electrons shields the
cations from each other
preventing violent repulsion and
allowing the metal to change
shape the most malleable metal is gold
a similar property to the malleability
of metals
is their ability to be pulled into long
thin wires
we call this ductility ionic compounds
are not ductal
for the same reason they are not
malleable in general
if an ionic compound is forced into a
long cylinder
it breaks apart because of the repulsion
of like ions
in contrast a metal can be pulled into a
long cylindrical shape
because the cations can line up shielded
from each other
as the fluid-like sea of electrons flows
around them
that's my favorite part the most ductile
metal
oh the most ductile metal what is it
they never know
it's platinum but see now okay okay now
that's a
i just gave it away okay
ductile malleable sea of electrons
sea of electrons because did you see
them
flowing around you're moving the atom
that was like a dance thing
that could be like a new dance move that
you try out tonight the sea of electrons
dance move i'm just saying
that so the sea of elect i'm not gonna
do it again but the sea of electrons
is able to move around the ions as
they're distorting because the metal
bond is not so directional
the metal bond is not so directional
because think about it what is holding
the metal together
it's these interactions between the
house and the kids that are roaming all
over the place
there's a kid over there over there it
doesn't matter just give me a
give me a little bit of positive you
know a little bit of negative charge so
i can feel an attraction
but that's the metal that's why
it is so able to deform in the way it
does
right because those atoms are moving
around and the electrons are just kind
of there as this happy c and the bonding
remains it doesn't break that's the key
otherwise this thing would just crack so
why are pulling
check this one out you can take a 10
centimeter
by one centimeter
platinum rod and you can spin that into
a wire and this is done
this is a very thin case for effect but
you can make
a 0.006 millimeter
diameter wire and you get
27.77 kilometers of wire
now that's because of ductility the only
reason i can get from
point a to point b there is because i'm
not breaking this apart and that's how
thin i can get
27 millimeter sorry diameter
when i pull it and i thought that was a
really good example of
why this matters because
maybe you've noticed but wires are
really important to us
right we use them a lot and and so
you know you just saw a cartoon with
electrons
here's a cartoon that i thought was
interesting
um that shows kind of a wire pulling set
up
so now this is there's
eye reducing the diameter that's a
double further reduction can take place
using
extra dyes the drawn wire is finally
wound on a spool
this transformation elongates the wire
one meter of 5.5 millimeter wire rod
can be drawn to 30 meters with one
millimeter diameter
or 484 meters with 0.25 millimeters damp
okay now that is a cartoon
and um and i think you know it's always
good when you see cartoons like this
you know you don't know go look up what
the real deal is
what does it really look like to draw
wires and i found
pretty cool so this is an actual wire
drawing plant
okay and this is what it looks like now
there's no audio here but i just want to
show you the magnitude those are huge
towers that are melting metals to give
you
this first rod right and then it goes
through one
after the other and look at it being
pulled being pulled in at some diameter
and it comes out at a different diameter
right
but i wanted to show you the scope and
size of this okay so there
is this is just one of there's a person
and so you get a sense of the
of the size and then you can also see
something when you go visit these
factories
and i have visited these factories
there's always a lot of this happening
why things are getting really hot right
when you're spinning things like wire at
a very high velocity
things heat up so you get water all over
the place right so there's water
being sprayed in factories all over the
place
because you got to keep stuff cool or
there's water baths that you run these
things through
right and then you got to think about
well does this thing interact with water
how does the water play a role it all
comes down to the electrons
and it once they've actually drawn the
wire out over this huge factory
they can actually weave it back together
so i found this this is the same factory
now these things here are doing the
opposite so these are huge drums
about the size of a person and each of
these got
a wire that was drawn right
and now again because of the ductility
you can
you can also move the wires play with
the wires and you can weave them
together
you can weave them right back together
into a thread that looks like that which
we all have seen
you know i think many many times all of
this
processing all of this manufacturability
has to do with the electron c
that's why we have wires okay
now a couple more small points
so we're going to go back to this
picture because
this is how we started um
and when this is that 1d
remember that 1d model that we used
to introduce band theory all right
and i want to go back to this
um because what you can see
is that you know
if i if i think about this as
bonding and anti-bonding orbitals all
kind of
mixed in here then you can also get a
sense
but just like in the the the dimers that
we made
right n2 o2
right remember no bond order
right it counts how many electrons are
in an antibonding orbital doesn't just
because it's in an anti-bonding orbital
doesn't mean it's not there
in the system it's the same with these
metal bands
right some of them may be good for
bonding some of them may not
but just like in the dimers the bond
order is related to
you know the strength of that bond
remember right and then no it's like a
bond order of two and a half and then if
i took an electron
out it actually got stronger the bonding
got stronger
it's the same thing in the case you can
think about this the same way
in metals you have a band i mean some of
these orbitals are not going to be
bonding orbitals and some of them are
going to be much more about the bonding
and and so that's going to relate to
things
like boiling point right so like
you know metals have boiling points too
right
and so if you look now go back to the
periodic table
remember the highest electrical
conductivity was here well that had to
do
with with that right there right with
the the position
with the filling of the orbitals to give
me the freest electron i can imagine
right after those d orbitals are filled
that s
but but if i'm thinking about whether i
filled anti-bonding orbitals
because now i'm thinking about the
strength of the bonds you see a
different trend and you see
something that you would expect first of
all you see a huge variability
but you see that the ones that are
strongest the highest boiling points
are going to be the ones where you fill
that band
those those bands roughly halfway
right and this is also why
you know in a metallic bond in a
metallic bond
you've got this enormous range right so
you've got
um you know it's the weakest
for elements like you know for elements
with near empty
near empty
valence
shells right valence subshells
i don't think you know like uh okay
cesium
is an example uh or
near full
like for example in mercury now
mercury is actually a liquid at room
temperature because of this
right there it is there it is right
you know why because i've i've
remembered like the beryllium dimer
right like i filled all these electrons
in there
and and they're they're causing this
really weak bonding
right this really weak bonding because i
had to put all of them into the
antibonding orbitals
i couldn't do this trick that right over
here right one column next to it
these guys can have tricks where they
you know now this is this is bonding
strength this is not electrical
conductivity
right but here they're filling the d and
then the s
is free not here here they're all filled
bonding and anti-bonding
no tricks now uh
if you look at the the melting
temperature that's why the one of the
strongest elements would be tungsten
right
strongest would be
example tungsten where you've got
a range of melting the melting point of
tungsten
and this is not the same as the boiling
point the melting point of tungsten
is 36 80 degrees c
that's a liquid at room temperature
and the melting point of cesium
is 28 degrees c
look at that range and it all has to do
with how these electrons are filling the
metallic bands and more than that
because it also has to do with the way
the atoms come together
and that is going to be the topic of
next week now that would
would have been a perfect line to end on
because i said the words next week but i
just want to make one more point
i can't stop because there's one more
thing i want to show
very quickly in one minute and that is
you know going back to this picture
right if you're thinking about filling
right and i've got like my 3s remember
i've got like my 3s
okay and okay let's
let's put 2p here and then
3s and 3p now remember
for metals for a lot of these metals
what ends up happening
is what i showed you before on wednesday
which is that
you get actually an overlap of this so
you get a band
that would be the 3s 3p band
sodium magnesium aluminum these are all
come together like this to form a single
band
now remember i don't need you to know
how to do this
we would tell you if it does this or not
right we talked about that i'm not going
to ask you to know
you know how these come together do they
form a continuous band or not
but in this case they do for that row
and so you know
i've got eight electrons eight electron
capacity
in that band per atom
that's the capacity of the band so now i
want to talk about how is this band
filled well for sodium
i'm gonna fill it 1 8 because it's got
just one electron that it's putting into
that band
right and for magnesium right for
magnesium
i'm going to fill it with two electrons
and aluminum
would be three
and so on okay so so it goes back to the
same picture as before we're filling the
bands
but now we've got 10 to the 23rd 24th
atoms
and so we think about filling the bands
as you know
how what's the occupancy per atom that
you could put in there
right and so i could tell you if i had a
mole of sodium how many electrons i have
in this band right it's a mole
right and how did you fill it and that
ties into what i just talked about which
is how that
relates to bonding strength okay now we
can stop
on monday we will start talking about
crystals
have a very good weekend
you